my extended family to this day even five
and a half years being on t they still
misgender me
and they still call me by my dead name
we ask trans men who have been on t for
different lengths of time the same
questions to see how time has shaped
their feelings about the experience
[Music]
my name is lucky i am 41 and i've been
on t for approximately 11 years my name
is marcus i'm 27 years old and i've been
on t for five and a half years now my
name is marcel i am 27 years old and
i've been on t for two and a half years
my name is gibby
i'm 18 years old and i've been on t for
five months hi my name is noah i'm 17
years old and i start t in two days
i was probably like eight years old i
always just would choose to be the guy
in any like situation like playing with
friends and when i was younger i want to
be the dad like i was very young
actually i hated being called beautiful
i hated being referred to as she or
ma'am and i felt more
at peace when someone called me handsome
or he
i was probably six years old that's
crazy i was eight when i found out that
i wasn't biologically born male but
there was no language 20 years ago there
was no language
them near 10 years ago
the first moment i took my tee shot it
felt like wow like i'm on the road to
being who i feel like inside i did have
a little bit of point where i had too
much testosterone my system and i was
very much
a
ball of rage and then i kind of went to
therapy and you know we calmed that down
a little bit i can't cry
like i'll feel sad like don't get that
wrong but the tears i don't know if
you're going to get them that day like
i'm kind of a lot more irritable i kind
of feel like i have a little more short
of reviews
but
after being on t for a couple months and
five months is like i have a motivation
to get up
my relationship with my body and gender
dysphoria
it's kind of
like a ongoing war
kind of like prison i was just really
disconnected with myself um it was very
much to a point where i couldn't look at
myself in the mirror i would shower in
the dark shower at night like it was
pretty bad
coming into my truth coming into my body
i was a 44 double d i gained a lot of
weight on purpose that way the rest of
me matched my top it was hard to be in
that body it was hard to know
that i was in there but no one can see
me
personally it was almost comparable of
like finding like a room stacked with
gold to like up to the ceiling it was
just like wow like this is the missing
piece like this is what has had me been
filling off this entire time and i was
ecstatic
initially
when i was with my ex i was socially
appearing as a woman my mom was like
you're not going to cut your hair while
you're in this house and as soon as i
got kicked out i was like fa i'm going
to cut my hair and i remember cutting my
hair dressing masculine that day um
binding my chest and i just broke down
crying in the bathroom and then my ex
fiance came in there and was like are
you okay and i was like
i i think you know i don't want you to
hate me but i think i'm a man when i
first came out to my parents it was
actually an accident because my freshman
year we had to write letters to our
senior selves i you know was addressing
myself using he him pronouns and my dad
had to write
a letter and he came across my own
letter and he seemed very upset
very confused that hurt a lot because
that's my own dad you know
my mental health pre-t i made multiple
suicide attempts i couldn't really tell
you a number that's how bad it was pre-t
i was definitely
suicidal
i hated my life i hated my body i hated
that i was not on hormones or doing what
i wanted to because i wanted to please
my family my mental health before i went
on t what it looked like was kind of
this foggy image
i was stagnant
like stuck
my friends have always been there for me
but i still felt so alone because i
didn't have the support from my family i
was asking my dad
if i could start t he just disapproved
he just basically told me a lot of awful
things i broke down i had a whole panic
attack and
i ended up going to the psych ward it
was around march of this year 2021 and
when i got out my parents have been like
actually trying to use my right name and
like fight pronouns i was told that i
was going to go to hell
um by one of my my theas on my mom's
side i remember had my suicide attempt
and she told my mom basically that this
was me being punished for being trans my
extended family till this day even five
and a half years being on t they still
misgender me um and they still call me
by my dead name my sisters were actually
the ones that vocalized the most that
they were never gonna be on board and
they're actually my number one fans like
took me to my surgeries always check in
on me my support system is a lot bigger
um and now it includes my parent well it
includes my mom it includes my kids it
includes my wife it includes my
grandkids
i have not experienced any transphobia
in the medical field yet and i really
hope i don't and like the nurses doctors
have actually been really supportive
they have also been really helpful to my
parents and educating them i absolutely
experienced transphobia in the medical
field you know all of the medical
providers that i came across at that
particular time
didn't want to deal with trans people
they didn't know how to deal with trans
people that that put me in a space where
i'm like well if you don't care about me
then why should i
what i fear the most as being a trans
man is
being discriminated against just being
beat up i fear for my life
my greatest fear as a trans man is being
killed my greatest fear being a trans
man
is death
i'm redefining being a man and manhood
by saying gender roles
[ __ ] all these norms i get to be whoever
i want to be it's okay to be feminine
sometimes and i don't ever like look
down upon my feminine side at all yeah
sometimes i paint my nails i'm a drag
king as well so like i want to break
down those walls as much as i can i get
to show up however i choose
as a man and it doesn't have to look
like masculinity looks like for everyone
else my masculinity looks like eating
gummy bears in the middle of my living
room coloring in the coloring book as
opposed to being giving this narrative
that we have to be stoic and we have to
be independent and strong and we can't
show emotion
noah i'm so proud of you
for
staying alive i love you i love myself a
lot me telling myself that i love myself
and that i'm so proud of myself
definitely hit home
you're becoming this
fantastic young man and if you just keep
being you and just keep making other
people laugh and love life you're gonna
be good i thought that i was going to
not make it to even 21 and here i am 27
years all gonna be 28 and
know that i am loved and that i am cared
for and i have a great support system
in this very moment the message i would
like to send to myself is keep going
i would say
be gentle with yourself
and i'm proud of you
keep going
you